hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara just saw and since I
missed last week's this week's episode
is on so of course I'm repping a little
light Mara here
you all knew I was gonna do that
obviously okay so my background with
Aquaman is not extensive comic book wise
I think I've only ever read Aquaman in
groups I've never read just like
straight up Aquaman comics I've seen a
bunch of reference photos but I've never
delves dives doe divin into Aquaman
comics he's always been pretty silly to
me there's a meme floating around on
Facebook recently where Aquaman is stuck
in one of those six-pack soda plastic
holders you know the ones ruining the
environment and he's stuck in one and it
just like this guy gets a ruby and it
made me laugh it's really funny and I
find Aquaman to be kind of a silly dude
I also am under the assumption that he
kind of started off as a silly dude in
the comics and then he got a little bit
more serious and more intense and badass
as time went on but that's just
something I've heard floating around the
internet I don't actually know that to
be true I just I've always seen him as
kind of like a cheesy fun addition to
the Justice League but never someone who
I really want a full movie for you know
Aquaman to me has always just been a
pretty self-aware cheesy superhero
seeing the trailers for this movie
though did not excite me I think in a
few videos I've mentioned that I was not
excited to see this movie I thought that
the CGI looks really really bad and way
too abundant and I was not excited for
Jason Momoa to be honest I've not really
seen him in anything except for being
Aquaman in Justice League so I don't
watch Game of Thrones I read the books
and then going to see the movie
this movie is a cheese fest it's a
festival of Jesus everything is so
over-the-top and cheesy there's romantic
comedy cheese and there's action cheese
and the script is cheesy as hell and
it's just there's a lot of dairy going
on for under the seat it's a cheesy Mago
man to me has always just been a pretty
self-aware cheesy superhero that's what
they were trying to do it was on purpose
I had a really good time with this movie
I thought it was crazy cheesy but I
think the Lord above the the ocean God
or what I his brother calls himself
ocean master that it was cheesy because
if this was a dark moody broody DC film
god that would have been insufferable
this was fun it seems to be aware of
itself in all of its cheesy glory and it
was not a pain to get through which I
find is true for a lot of DC films
definitely still some some
heart-wrenching moments of seriousness
in there for the most part this is just
like 2 hours and 20 minutes of just
cheese it seems that it was intentional
and it was fun for the most part I will
say wasn't a humongous fan of the 20 to
40 minutes that could have easily been
cut from this movie it was way too long
there were some total moments of just
like why why why who why is this being
dragged out so much and I guess it was a
fun movie but there were some moments
where it like it would have been so much
more fun if it was 40 minutes short I
thought the world building was awesome
there's different circuits in the ocean
of different ocean people and ocean folk
and those were flippin awesome the
design of some of the characters super
super cool the CGI with the the thing
that I thought was just gonna ruin the
movie for me was really well done I'm
not someone who likes to watch an all
CGI movie avatar didn't really get it
so this wasn't my cup of tea I would say
but for going and thinking I really
really wasn't gonna love it I had a
really fun time with it and for a movie
that's all CGI like this you know
majority CGI that's surprising I think
for me personally to say that and so I
think for someone who does enjoy CGI
yikes you're gonna love this movie the
acting was killer
they hired some really good people in
this who really believed the stakes and
really believed at the conflict that
they were talking about and it worked
out well Jason Momoa was just living yes
Queen and all of the scenes that he was
in he was having a blast it seemed and
that's so much fun to watch he is this
just giant of course beautiful you know
seafolk man and to see him be silly in
that character is the perfect mix thing
I know there's a lot of people who don't
enjoy a ton of comedy in their superhero
movies nowadays because Marvel's really
gone pretty hard into the comedy in
action kind of world which I happen to
love but I know a lot of people don't
love it like Thor Ragnarok came out
people like okay and this which I also I
understand that point of view I love
that but this I still think will be
enjoyable for you because no one can go
into Aquaman being like if there's just
not a bunch of blood and guts and
intense war and no apps for me then I
just don't know if you're going to
commit but the right mindset
personally is my opinion Nicole Kidman I
love to Nicole Kidman in this I have
such a soft spot for her and that woman
was a badass in this movie she has a
fight scene that just are you joking me
there's some definite CGI some effects
done to make her look younger at a point
also I feel like they did that to
Patrick Wilson who plays Aquaman's
brother the ocean master which god he
got the better nickname
I'll say ocean master versus Aquaman
Aquaman pretty okay you know you get the
gist of what he's about but ocean master
that's Patrick Stewart also a really
great very focused on his intentions as
an actor this film I think I saw a
little bit of you know some stuff done
to his face as well to make him look
younger it felt didn't really bother me
it was just noticeable I will say I
thought God what's your name Oh Mara
Amber Heard didn't even have to look it
up hell yeah Tamra you you crested it I
know you're dressed up as her right now
so you should okay she's strong she's
cool and then also at parts I think that
the scripts did her and Jason Momoa and
their relationship a disservice there's
one part where they go full-on romantic
comedy and it's it's a lot it's just
that was I don't it was a misstep I
think that was a little just diving too
much into the cheese factor I also wish
that she had gotten to showcase her
powers a little bit more again I don't
know much about I'll come in and so I
didn't know the powers that she
possessed and then she starts showing
him off at the end
I like up for a little bit doing some
really cool things that could have been
just expanded upon like crazy it was
really great to see those things I
didn't know about them at all and and
and then also I feel like she could have
done so much more with those powers at
times she was way more powerful than
Aquaman was because she was still kind
of you know figuring himself out so it
was cool to see her use that I think
they could have gone way further with
that and hopefully if they do another
Aquaman they will I also really enjoyed
that they didn't make this about the
Justice League there was no Wonder Woman
cameo which I thought was great I loved
Wonder Woman she's my favorite in the
DCU but sometimes it she's gotta be
about Aquaman you know that's you've
been my catchphrase for a long time
I think the action sequences were really
fun really well done super well
choreographed and Jason Momoa looks
badass in everything that he does again
I think the things the movie really
lacked on are some parts in the scripts
the story didn't flow in a way that it
should have in some moments and then
also I just think it was too long I
think they could have cut out some of
the things in the script and that
probably would have made it flow a
little bit better Oh with the script
there are some really great one-liners
like ocean master and you ask sea for
mercy it's a great one-liner I tell like
that all the time oh you want food right
now you ask the sea for mercy it makes
sense don't worry about it don't think
that's one thing I wrote it's Mara your
eyebrows are brown which I shouldn't say
anything about cos so a mine but mm-hmm
I don't have millions of dollars for
this budget so that just was a little
odd like they're very Brown and her hair
is very red there was it didn't seem
like any attempt that's just a personal
thing I bet there's gonna be a ton of
comments of people being like I am right
here in brown eyebrows I'm ashamed was
just a little weird it's a little
jarring it's just a small thing that I
saw I'm sorry Brooke filming this must
have been so annoying because they had
to constantly be drenched that sucks
I imagine filming movies at this caliber
like this just giant of a project must
have been so long so taxing they're just
drenched all the time they have to act
outside of themselves
everything is CGI so you're just kind of
talking to this little man in a green
suit who's supposed to be this crab or
this octopus who's playing the goddamn
drums and so you really have to bring
out a lot in that and to their credit
they did such a good job are we gonna
address how they jumped out of a plane
into San and were unharmed
I don't know maybe I just didn't get
that but is that in their powers okay
one thing I did laugh at is before I saw
the movie I was on Twitter and I saw
someone write that after this movie
Marvel really needs to step their game
up and I wouldn't go that far
I had a fun time with this it was a mess
there were some definite problems but
overall it was just really full of heart
and the actors just did this this movie
such a solid by being all in like 115
percent and it really brought it over
the top
and I think also the direction
definitely had apartment and and
everyone working on the CGI was very
skilled at what they were doing and all
these things came together to make a
great movie
do I think that Marvel needs to be
scared and set their game up no do I
think this needs to be something that is
compare it to Marvel no I think this was
a real hit for DC I think it was a real
swing and a hit and I'm excited to see
where they go moving forward with
Aquaman and and I can't wait to see the
new Wonder Woman second Suicide Squad
it's gonna be a gonna be a great thing I
think cautiously optimistic that we have
a promising future for DC Comics DC
movies not DC Comics those are
incredible but you know what I mean okay
thank you so much for watching I will
see you all next week
in the new year thanks for watching this
year I'll see you then
you
[Music]